reza aslan someone who has been held out
as the pinnacle of intellectual
discussion regarding Islamic apologetics
just said I no longer need to argue my
point because everyone who disagrees
with me is a bigot reza aslan who's one
of the biggest Islamic apologists you
see out there on cable news has somehow
gotten a pass as though he's an
intellectually honest or critical
thinker who presents very compelling
arguments for Islam we've had so many
people saying why don't you have him on
it's very hard
we'll have our Booker come on with the
list of people who've refused to do the
program reza aslan is a social justice
warrior personified this is what I would
like to presuppose reza aslan is not an
intellectual he's a social justice
warrior just like a Laci green just like
a Bernie Sanders just like a Vox and
I think by the end of this segment I can
prove it to you let's roll the first
clip you are according to the FBI
more likely to die as the result of
faulty furniture than by an Islamic
terrorist so you should really be scared
of your lazy boy ok so right away you
should be starting to see the
similarities this is an argument no no
this argument is intellectually lazy boy
see what I did there this is so this is
this is it's obviously it's such an
intellectually lazy argument ok a couple
of things first up I don't know what
kind of numbers you're using because
Barack Obama's farewell address he just
said that there were no known terrorist
attacks on American soil
under his watch that things were better
that global terrorism was down I don't
know Fort Hood Chattanooga Boston
bombers so maybe those aren't being
included where he's talking about the
unlikelihood of a terrorist attack
globally they occur all the time every
day people are killed in the name of
Islam at very very high record numbers
consistently so I don't know the numbers
that he's using there but let's remove
that from the table ok I'm going to give
him as much leeway as possible a lazy
boy a piece of furniture as an inanimate
object it doesn't have an evil ideology
it doesn't have a violent ideology
that's like saying well statistically
it's very unlikely that you will be
sexually manat many pet you're more
likely to drown in the pool Johnny then
be raped by a pedophile so just don't
walk by the pedophiles house anyone
who's watching this if you want to think
this is someone who is intellectually
genuine do you really think he's dumb
enough to not see what a horrible
comparison that is that's that's that's
not a valid analogy chairs furniture
they do not have an ideology that can
kill people Islam does in record numbers
so don't try and compare them next clip
I grew up in a predominantly Mexican
community so I just told everybody I was
Mexican
Oh practicing Islamic Takeya as a
toddler very nice for those who don't
know look up Islam takea next clip
hardest part for me when I'm being
interviewed is to tamp down my
astonishment the question at the bottom
of the screen that everyone is looking
at this Islam promote violence the thing
that's mostly going through my mind is
calm down calm down the justice system
in Muslim countries you don't think is
somehow more primitive or subjugates
women more than in other countries did
you hear what you just said you said in
Muslim countries yes yes she did this is
another tactic of the social justice
warrior just act like it's so absurd oh
so you just like people could vote for
Donald Trump and they're not racist did
you see what you just said let me fade a
fence with my with my perfectly strand
plucked eyebrows it's a perfectly valid
question as a matter fact I think it's a
necessary question Muslim countries know
that you should be happy about this Reza
Aslan she's not saying all Muslims
hashtag not all Muslims she's saying as
a general rule in Islamic countries do
we acknowledge that maybe there's a
systemic problem in their treatment of
women let alone gays let alone people
who aren't Muslim we'll get to that in a
moment she is saying as a general rule
in the Islamic world does it stand to
reason your honor to say that they have
not stepped up with the rest of the
modernized world in Western society well
what about the fact that I think we have
these sources 85% globally and Muslim
believe that women should always obey
husband's try and tell that to MTV
feminist news and see what they think
about everywhere is say Christians that
fifty-three percent believe women can be
punished for not wearing veils more than
half the Muslims in the world believe
women should not have the right to
divorce or equal rights to inheritance
here's the point these are not
extremists these are statistics
verifiable statistics across the Islamic
world does that mean that there aren't
variances between say Indonesia or
actually they might be pretty nice to
women but there's record church burnings
as it occurs with Christians right now
but we don't talk about that no it
doesn't mean that of course Pakistan is
going to be worse and somebody
maybe worse with gay people in the UAE
maybe worse with rape we understand that
there are variances across the Islamic
world but for her to ask the question as
a general rule hashtag not all Muslims
our equal rights of problem the Islamic
world and Reza Aslan wants you to
believe that that is an unreasonable
question that can be attributed also
something that social justice warriors
constantly accuse their opponents of and
we'll get to that let's go to next
please don't generalize about 1.7
billion people in the world okay let's
not let's not generalize about 1.7 how
about 1.2 billion how about 1.2 billion
people in the world I've got some
statistics here we did a video on this
bench up here did a great video on this
we have 52 percent of American Muslims
who support some form of Sharia law a
quarter of American Muslims the most
moderate in the world support jihad then
if you look in other countries like
Pakistan you have seventy five percent
of people who support strict Sharia law
over two thirds support honor killings
you can go across the spectrum you can
go to Saudi Arabia you can go to
Pakistan you can go to Indonesia you can
go to Malaysia you can go to UAE you can
go to Iran you can go to Egypt you'll
find these numbers pretty consistent at
least 20 something percent of Muslims if
they aren't and get of course aren't
engaged in terrorism but actively
support terrorist organizations or
believe that it's justified
so 1.2 million at 1.2 billion Muslims
who believe in some form of Sharia law
or death for apostasy right we know that
now I know you'll say will Sharia law
it's not the same in every okay that's
true let's allow for some variances
sharia law generally has some pillars
that are pretty important meaning
dhimmitude subjugation of people who are
non-muslim meaning women are treated
differently from men under the law
meaning non-muslims are treated
differently under the law meaning gay
people tend to be stoned to death
meaning women need certain people for
rape meaning there is death for apostasy
those are generally considered I know
there's different Sharia law but if you
look across the board as a general rule
hashtag not all Muslims those tend to be
included in Sharia law let's take that
back
let's take it to less than half let's
say 500 million Muslims in the world
believe in Sharia law or 500 million
Muslims believe in honor killings or
death for apostasy we know guaranteed
it's much higher than that I'm saying
let's scale back 1.2 billion let's scale
it back to 900
and scale it back to 500 million Muslims
on planet earth who believe in
implementing laws that violate basic
fundamental human rights that's not a
problem am I making a generalization
with 500 million people the Westboro
Baptist Church who are talked about
every time they send out a press release
have about 16 members and two of them
have flippers next clip you're a Muslim
so why did you write a book about the
founder of Christianity well to be clear
I am a scholar of religions with four
degrees including one in the New
Testament and fluency in biblical Greek
to be fair that was an incredibly stupid
question that question was everything
that is wrong with cable news I worked
at Fox News for four years I've appeared
at every cable network known to man and
I agree that that was an incredibly
stupid question it was a leading
question it was irrelevant that's one
for you reza aslan after about 10 years
of being cable News's favorite Muslim
I've come to the realization that I
don't think it's doing any good bigotry
is not a result of ignorance as a result
of fear and fear is impervious to data
fear is impervious to information I know
when I said Reza Aslan is a social
justice warrior a lot of people who are
still in their conversion process from
the young turks no no I don't wanna know
actually did you see what he did holla
he did the exact same thing every social
justice leftist does he said I used to
do it but now I absolve myself of the
requirement to make intellectual
arguments because all of my opponents
anyone who disagrees with me are bigoted
bigotry is impervious to information do
you see what he just did it was the same
thing that the Obama supporters did with
the Tea Partiers the same thing that
Hillary supporters and Bernie people did
with Donald Trump supporters the same
thing the social justice warriors do
online which is if you disagree with me
you're racist reza aslan someone who has
been held out as the pinnacle of
intellectual discussion regarding
Islamic apologetics just
said I no longer need to argue my point
because everyone who disagrees with me
is a bigot I could rest my case here but
let's go further in this country we went
from overwhelming majorities who were
against same-sex marriage to
overwhelming majorities supporting
same-sex marriage within the span of a
couple of years right okay so when is
that span of a couple years occurred
anywhere in the Islamic world yet Reza
Aslan mr. mr. left I know I know you're
incredibly anti-israel and support
Palestine how did your your meeting with
the Hamas committee go do they notice
your Lisp perchance I noticed you're
still intact so I guess not
let's go through the statistics turkey
is violent homophobia of course ret
crimes against gay people that if it
occurred anywhere in the modern world it
would be all over YouTube and Facebook
and they wouldn't even remove it as fake
news Saudi Arabia they push for gays to
be executed Bangladesh let's look there
that's the country I think Reza Aslan
has used as one of his examples for
moderate Islam what are their thirteen
Islamic countries at officially your
team sir so I get it hate crimes at
parades and stuff you know that you
can't that's anecdotal again let's give
let's give reza aslan as much leeway as
possible
all those hate crimes that occur against
gay people in record rates that don't
occur in the modern world let's remove
those still 13 Islamic countries that
kill you for being a sprite so uh he
praises that here in the United States
why don't you go out of your way to talk
about where it's still a problem he
seems he seems very obsessed with the
gay issue to constantly defending its
own articles oh you know what maybe he's
just a compassionate person next clip
what changed people's minds was Will &
Grace was Modern Family was watching
people who were gay on television being
you know normal they're struggling with
the same issues that you're struggling
with they are human beings
and so for the last few years I've
decided that what I'm gonna do is try to
change people's minds through pop
culture through film and television ah
there it is and it's a great point it's
a great point from Reza Aslan it also
serves to debunk the idea that
conservatives or anyone who's not a
social justice warrior some crazy
conspiracy theorist when they believe
that the entertainment industry and
media are colluding against their values
here you go straight from the Islamic
horses possibly gay mouths Reza Aslan
here says I am going to use a will and
grace you know Modern Family
he says Hollywood serves to brainwash
people Hollywood serves to act as prop
because here's a deal right is he using
Hollywood to bring people together does
he want to use pop culture to bring
people together no he doesn't because he
just dismissed half of the entire
country is bigoted racist remember that
so what does he want to do he wants to
use pop culture media news to dismiss
and brainwash everybody into believing
that all these people are racist and
they're bigoted and they're homophobic
and they're transphobic so let's put
more [ __ ] in superwoman let's put
more let's put more gay people and I
don't know any single show let's
whatever it is at every single turn they
have to put something in there to inject
a social justice we need more
superheroes who are black we need more
female superheroes who have a jobs we
need to do that because now pop culture
so they're they're framing you all as
bigoted this is reza aslan the great
intellectual islamic thinker people who
disagree with me are bigoted but really
maybe people who disagree with you it
doesn't mean they're bigoted if they
disagree with passages in the Quran that
say kill infidels wherever you find them
sura 434 i could rattle off some verses
for you is it doesn't mean they're
bigoted if they're let's say you don't
even have an opinion but they're a bit
concerned that according to hadith
muhammad called for the deaths of
christians and jews as his last words
does it mean you're bigoted if Mohammed
beat his six-year-old wife does it mean
you're bigoted if Mohammed came out and
said you know what I think it was
wrestling with a demon and his wife said
no no that was that that was an angel
and that's how the religion started
is it bigoted if Christians maybe go at
listen I think this is a perversion of
the Christian faith or even Jewish
people who say you know anything this is
a perversion of the Old Testament
because they think of everything after
to Abraham's blessing was a lie is it
bigoted for people to have any kind of
apprehensions with Islam Reza Aslan says
yes that can be the only reason and he
is going to serve the rest
of his life brainwashing the public to
ensure that they agree with him ladies
and gentlemen I rest my case
hey if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit com /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than six dollars a month and
you get daily content no more clips plus
this hand at smug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside